[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
[Música]
Bienvenidos en Primera Plana un programa
de radiofrance internacional y de France
24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
Argentina un país que se adentra en un
ciclo electoral apasionante y con
muchísima incertidumbre por la situación
económica y la polarización que vive el
país para ello nos acompañan en este
estudio tres invitados ya les presento a
Gabriel Jiménez roche es profesor de
economía en la neoma business School
bienvenido Muchas gracias maricel
Rodríguez blanco socióloga del instituto
católico de París bienvenida Muchas
gracias
periodista independiente especializado
en Latinoamérica bienvenido
Argentina año electoral hoy nuestro
asunto en Primera Plana
[Música]
el presidente Alberto Fernández ha
llamado a la unidad del peronismo en
este año electoral que se abre en el
país Argentina tendrá primarias abiertas
el próximo 13 de agosto y ahí se
definirán los candidatos de las
elecciones generales de octubre un
calendario electoral al que argentina se
aproxima con inflación disparada en un
país que siempre parece estar al borde
del precipicio se calcula que el 45%
vive bajo la línea de la pobreza todo
esto en un ambiente de campaña de
crispación y de irritación con gobierno
y oposición hablando en términos muy
Duros de calle regadas de sangre y
muertos o de dinamitarlo todo
repasemos algunas portadas que nos deja
la prensa la nación el fmi admite un
replanteo del acuerdo para evitar el
agravamiento de la crisis el diario El
País en España el derrumbe de la
economía Argentina pone a prueba la
capacidad de gestión de un peronismo
fracturado la revista en su edición
Argentina ha dedicado su portada al
líder de la extrema derecha Javier milei
a quien representa Como si fuese el
el único precandidato que crece
en las encuestas dice la publicación
bueno quedan todavía unos meses para las
elecciones en Argentina pero ya este
ambiente de crispación Gabriel no se va
a vaticinar una calma necesaria digamos
para el buen funcionamiento democrático
del país a partir de esta constatación
ya A falta de unos meses no es buen
vaticinio
está fracturado el país hay una
polarización de la población o sea que
la población se divide mucho ahora
ideológicamente entre izquierda y
derecha cosas que tal vez siempre
existió pero ahora de una forma mucho
más violenta tal vez verbalmente Bueno
hay que tener en consideración eso de
dinamitar todo calles ensangrentadas
Bueno también es muy argentino Eh sí sí
pero sin embargo Sí por ejemplo mi ley
que propone reformar todo de forma
drástica e inmediata bullrich también
sin embargo de Sergio massa va más hacia
la moderación y hay que ver pero si las
situaciones económicas grave pero ya es
grave hace mucho tiempo en Argentina los
argentinos más o menos
aprendieron a vivir así ahora pero
realmente la cuestión es esa negociación
con el fmi Y qué va a pasar después
luego hablaremos de esa negociación
maricel vamos a intentar plasmar El
retrato de electoral que tenemos con el
gobierno la posición también la extrema
derecha Alberto Fernández no se presenta
kirchner ya anunció que no será
candidata Pero quizá la primera pregunta
es hasta qué punto sigue manejando el
poder en el peronismo Cristina Fernández
Yo creo que Cristina Fernández es una
hábil política y con mucha capacidad
política y muchos años de militancia no
avisó digamos anunció que no se
presentaba sin embargo sigue siendo una
candidata que puede presentar puede ser
precandidato a pesar de la de la digamos
de la condena que pesa sobre ella Desde
diciembre como sabemos por la Corte
Suprema de Justicia
Y eso desde el punto de vista de la
interna digamos del peronismo es
importante es importante también saber
que tiene apoyos Incluso si ha sido se
ha debilitado su peso su imagen también
tiene incluso apoyos dentro del
peronismo que son todavía muy fuertes
ahora lo que queda por ver es cómo va a
poder realizar alianzas sobre todo con
los gobernadores de las provincias con
los caudillos provinciales para poder
construir un espacio y unificar un
espacio
kirchnerista que está efectivamente
fracturado y cuyo candidato
presidenciable digamos que aparece como
como el más realista es masa pero no es
el único
bueno es la es la que digamos la que
suma más votos o más apoyos En todo caso
dentro de ese espacio kirchnerista una
cosa que Podemos agregar es que moviliza
movilizado muchísimo la juventud los
jóvenes entre 14 y 25 años hay una buena
parte que están que entran a la política
por primera vez en el 2000 los años 2000
y sobre todo bajo el kirchnerismo y
tiene un apoyo muy importante de la
cámpora de una organización que es
militante política que interviene en la
economía
pertenecen los principales ministros y
del gobierno
vamos a seguir luego comentando esta
parte de Cristina pero Sergio más el
titular de economía que es el digamos no
sé si llamarle el favorito para obtener
esa candidatura oficialista en tiempos
muy adversos tanto para el oficialismo
como para la economía del país es Sergio
más ese candidato de consenso que
lograría unificar a un peronismo
fracturado por proponerlo así por el
momento no podemos decir a fuerzamente
que va a unir este el peronismo
es una figura muy muy importante en
Argentina es seguro que yo pienso que
hay votos también que va a ir por él
pero vemos Yo pienso que lo más
importante es de ver que todo lo que va
a pasar alrededor de Christina kirchner
tanto por el 25 de mayo que en las
próximas semanas Por el momento no
podemos decir pero es una persona muy
importante un candidato que puede ser
muy muy serio por este por la por la
coalición quería Añadir algo más
en realidad la cuestión de kirchner Es
que ella tiene mucho rechazo de la de
los indecisos digamos de otros electores
en el otro electorado que no sea
peronista sin embargo dentro del
peronismo ella tiene un electorado que
nunca la va a dejar y que son más o
menos 15 al 20% del electorado nacional
y que es joven es electorado
y nunca la va a dejar va a votar siempre
por ella o por gente que ella apoya no
pero la cuestión es que ya genera el
resto los otros 80 por ciento mucho
rechazo hay mucho rechazo Entonces tal
vez la idea sea ella se pone un poco
hacia atrás sin embargo va a apoyar va
a ungir un candidato peronista La
cuestión es ver quién Cómo y cómo va a
funcionar pero la última vez que el que
intentó una jugada le salió bastante
bien que fue la puesta bastante bien
digo de como cartel electoral de dar Un
paso atrás poner Alberto Fernández y en
un principio sí efectivamente fue una
estrategia muy sabia que funcionó en un
principio después se fue ahí demostró la
parte estratega que antes comentábamos
no exactamente sí sí no fue ciertamente
ahora visto lo que ha pasado últimamente
yo no sé si si va a ser la estrategia
que va a elegir a nuevamente digamos
elegir un candidato
presidenciable y ponerse como dice como
candidata a la vicepresidencia no bueno
como como se dice acá no no no no
podemos saber todavía qué es lo que va a
pasar la el 25 de Mayo es muy importante
en ese sentido porque va a ser una gran
movilización Nacional
los sectores por ejemplo de trabajadores
la cgt la apoyan Incluso si hay rechazos
dentro de esos sectores a Cristina
kirchner hay que acordarse que el
peronismo siempre fue un movimiento
dividido desde sus inicios en realidad y
siempre a lo largo de la historia
mostraron diferentes maneras de aliarse
de formar coaliciones e incluso en la
famosa transversalidad no que es la que
kirchner justamente Néstor kirchner puso
puso un poco en marcha luego vamos a
hablar del peronismo uno de los grandes
debates cada vez que hablamos con gente
Argentina porque es definir ya definir
ya el puro peronismo es apasionante pero
vamos a hablar antes de la oposición de
qué candidatos suenan y con Qué
diferencias entre ellos después de la
era macri
tenemos candidatos que estaban con macri
justamente son no son candidatos muy
nuevos son candidatos que que por
ejemplo sus ministros sus ministros
también quieren ir todavía no se sabe si
vamos el con Patricia este
es la comparativa de la misma forma que
hemos hablado del poder que tiene
Cristina Fernández dentro del peronismo
Qué cantidad de poder tendría macri de
controlar ahora mismo el candidato que
salga de la oposición por entendernos
hay un conflicto interno yo creo que hay
que descartar eso al dentro de esta la
coalición de macri y uno pienso que
macri también tiene un apoyo muy grande
como lo tuvo también antes Ahora hay
Horacio lagarta la reta y también y
también este del otro lado hay también
otros candidatos pero es como María
Eugenia también que puede ser también
otra también precandidata también no
sabemos muy bien por los conflictos
internos que quién macri va a apoyar
entonces esa coalición es decir los líos
que hay dentro del peronismo también se
trasladan como espejo a lo que pasa en
la oposición toda toda la lucha interna
toda la lucha intestina no por lo que
estamos en realidad hay que ver el más
cercano a macri sería la reta que bueno
que está más cercano Patricia el
bullrich viene de una familia Ya antigua
no de La Nobleza política Argentina y
ella más o menos independiente con
respecto a Mati hay que ver sin embargo
evidentemente todo este lío de alianzas
como va a ser quien pero por el momento
yo diría más macri va más hacia la recta
sin embargo macri tiene mucho rechazo
también el electoral argentino
solo agregar que Juntos por el cambio
que también es una coalición también
muy fracturada como se acaba de decir
esos esos candidatos que digamos resalen
hay que acordarse que la reta es jefe de
gobierno de la ciudad Autónoma de Buenos
Aires de la caba Y esa es una posición
clave también para convertirse en
candidato presidenciable por lo que hay
que pensar no solamente es los apoyos
internos que van a depender mucho de la
posibilidad de presidenciales de
candidato es decir que qué capacidad
tenga para construir una candidatura más
allá de ese y poder justamente aliar
algunos decepcionados digamos del
kirchnerismo y otro y otros sectores de
indecisos no el diez quince veinte por
ciento de indecisos va a ser clave en
las elecciones pues Por si la política
Argentina tuviera poco de pimienta a
esto llega un señor que se llama Javier
milei que vamos a intentar ahora
explicar Quién es y pone de manifiestos
su auge de momento en los sondeos no sé
si podemos definirlo como un movimiento
reaccionario frente a los momentos
sociales como el feminismo de amplia
trayectoria en el país Quién es Javier
milei de dónde sale Javier milei es un
economista más cercano a think Thanks
liberales radicales Incluso se fijaba
mucho en la cuestión en cuestiones
económicas de liberalización de la
economía no solamente privatización y
tenía posiciones al comienzo cuando era
más tertuliano que político que era más
de libertad económica y social Pero
bueno y siempre Tuvo una personalidad
muy abrasiva insultada periodistas
un lenguaje bastante floreado No no
recuerda mucho a Trump No sí Yo diría
que recuerda mucho a Trump en ese
sentido de tertuliano
platos y bueno a medida que se va
politizando se va acercando mucho al
electorado conservador argentino y
lo diferente Es que el movimiento de mi
ley de libertad avanza es el único que
está en realidad canibalizando a los dos
movimientos principales contra la
libertad o sea el peronismo el frente
para todos y
Juntos por el cambio pero podría llegar
a una segunda a una segunda vuelta
concretamente Yo pienso que soy más más
respecto de eso Habría que ver primero
mi ley es bueno es diputado nacional o
se tiene tiene una carrera política es
relevante relativamente corta y como
economista no es para nada conocido O
sea que si uno Busca las situaciones que
tiene sobre Google scholar por ejemplo
milay son
ínfimas O sea que nadie conoce su
producción tampoco como economista es
aprovechado un contexto social que es
grave digamos de de crisis social de
grieta social caracterizada por lo
conocemos desempleo que afecta más a las
mujeres que a los hombres desocupación
trabajo informal etcétera aprovechó eso
sobre todo porque tiene un grupo de
jóvenes que lo que lo siguen mucho entre
14 y 25 años un grupo etario que está
justamente atravesado por la
incertidumbre desde el punto de vista
del trabajo de su relación con el
trabajo el punto de vista laboral son
sobre todo hombres que lo que lo siguen
hombres jóvenes es un dato y dentro de
su movimiento ya hubo varias acusaciones
respecto de violencia de género y hay
que saber que en Argentina
Lamentablemente la violencia de género
sigue siendo una realidad hay centenas
cuatrocientas feminicidios por año
todavía eso no está resuelto a pesar de
las políticas que conocemos a ministro
de Gen Ministerio de género políticas de
género locales también relativamente
locales que se confrontan a una realidad
provincial que es muy dura que está
caracterizada por un peronismo duro como
decías peronismo conservador menemista
incluso Ah que viene de los caudillos
menemistas de los 90 en ese sentido
milai no aporta absolutamente nada nuevo
porque su proyecto es un proyecto de
austeridad de estado mínimo que viene
justamente a remontar digamos a los años
90 y se posiciona ahí para para defender
bueno todo eso caracterizado por nuevas
redes sociales
el presidente Turco recepta Jeep erdogan
enfrenta su mayor desafío electoral
en medio de una inflación creciente y
una popularidad en descenso el partido
oficialista akp Busca refrendarse en las
urnas Y obtener también mayorías en la
asamblea frente a una oposición
fortalecida Cómo quedará el poder
político en Turquía Hacia dónde va la
democracia turca siga nuestra cobertura
especial en France 24 France 24.com y en
nuestras redes sociales
seguimos en Primera Plana analizando el
ciclo electoral en el que se adentra
Argentina lo hacemos con un profesor de
economía Gabriel Jiménez con una
socióloga maricel Rodríguez y con un
periodista quillón ascari antes de irnos
a la pausa estábamos analizando la
figura de Javier milei el candidato de
extrema derecha estamos hablando de un
movimiento reaccionario que puede que
puede llegar al país estamos hablando de
la posibilidades que tendría en ese en
esas elecciones guillón no sé si querías
Añadir algo más sí a continuación de
todo lo que se decía justamente yo
quería agregar también dos cosas primero
Javier milei también es una persona que
lo comparamos con Trump sabe que ahora
también las elecciones no se también no
se votan a fuerzamente en y no se juegan
sobre todo en las calles es alguien que
sabe usar el tiempo sabe usarlo redes
sociales y también por eso le podemos
comparar a un bolso
Pero también es una persona también muy
radical que por su propuesta hay que hay
que hablar de eso tanto por la
dolarización del de la economía que
quiere que tanto tanto también por el
fin también del del Banco Central es una
persona que quiere también dos cosas que
ahora en Argentina o sea nadie en el
gobierno quiere hablar de eso tanto del
presidente que el jefe de gabinete que
los gobernadores Por qué también el peso
también fuera del valor que tiene
actualmente en Argentina sabemos por un
argentino el peso es muy importante
también es parte también cultural
también entonces este
Aprovechando que tenemos a Gabriel
Jiménez me gustaría preguntarle por el
peso que va a tener por ejemplo algo
como el acuerdo como el con el fmi que
la propia expresidenta Cristina
Fernández ha definido como lastre Qué
importancia va a tener una posible
renegociación dentro de la campaña
electoral Yo creo que el fmi ahora mismo
está esperando lo que va a suceder claro
De todas formas el gobierno argentino
actual no ha respetado el calendario de
lo que se pidió como reforma el déficit
fue dominado se sigue un déficit fiscal
muy fuerte en Argentina y lo que se está
hablando mucho últimamente es de
moratoria o sea vamos a parar un poco de
pagar para renegociar el término de la
de la deuda todo depende como dijo
guillón Javier Miley tiene propuestas
muy drásticas muy muy radicales
Patricia bullrich adoptó un discurso
últimamente también muy muy fuerte con
respecto a las reformas por ejemplo
también habla de eliminar el cepo
cambiario en el día desde el día cero
cosas que ya hizo macri y no funcionó
muy bien porque nos prepararon esa
salida del cepo cambiar Ok que realmente
hay que hacer pero no no se hace así
desde la noche para la mañana no ya masa
tiene propuestas más no diría ni
siquiera moderada son tibias porque yo
creo que también él no sabe qué va a
pasar con él se va a ser candidato o no
Entonces no no hay mucha definición el
que define un poco más que va a ser cómo
va a ser es mi y bueno Esto con el fmi
evidentemente nos va a cobrar eliminar
el Banco Central argentino no y en
cambio es curioso porque Sergio más
estos días habla mucho de que de no caer
en primarias estériles dice él un modo
de como de autodesignación no de querer
ya meterse como candidato Por qué se
entiende que unas primarias pueden
desgastar y no reforzar porque en teoría
un candidato que salga de las primeras
saldría reforzado y no desgastado Por
qué la pela lo contrario
porque las primarias paso las expensas
que hubo de la del uso de las primarias
que es súper interesante que es un
dispositivo que existe desde 2009 en
Argentina
Son simultáneas son elecciones primarias
simultáneas obligatorias abiertas no que
dentro de cada grupo coalicional como
estamos hablando de coaliciones tener
esas primarias es muy importante
justamente para medirse dentro de dentro
del grupo pero también para respecto de
otros de otros grupos políticos el miedo
además es justamente respecto de otros
candidatos justamente de candidatos
macristas el nieto de él salir Debi
digamos respecto de la fuerza que puede
tener otro candidato dentro del dentro
del macrismo en sus primeras en sus
pasos digamos y lo que quiere es evitar
justamente pasar por ahí que lo nombren
directamente como como candidato
presidenciable para evitar también que
otros candidatos dentro del espacio
kirchnerista puedan puedan pronunciarse
Igualmente digamos la presentación de
alianzas vence el 14 de junio dentro de
casi un mes y algunas dudas sobre el rol
que va a tener la propia Cristina
Fernández podría repetir fórmula de
alguna forma Como hizo con Alberto Pero
quizá con masa u otra forma o prefiero
un cálculo como de intentar liderar la
oposición que es lo que tiene en la
cabeza políticamente de la visión de
futuro Cristina Fernández Por el momento
se pone un poco en una posición de
injusticia yo le puedo comparar por
ejemplo a lo que vimos en Brasil con
nula y también a los seguidores también
de kirchner hoy día también
de víctima eso también tiene un tiene
una
divinidad tan grande actualmente en
Argentina frente a lo que pasó con la
justicia que también va en ese sentido
tanto en lo que vemos en las redes
sociales que también en los medios en
Argentina es de decir por la parte o sea
del cristianismo que que también apoya a
Cristina kirchner hoy día y que quiere
que que el 25 de mayo haya también hay
una movilización alrededor de ella
también para que anuncia su su su su su
su su candidatura porque ella goza de
una inmunidad actualmente hay que hay
que recordar eso también como como
vicepresidente entonces este vemos que
la posición que tiene es una posición de
decir y también los seguidores no va a
pasar como a Lula O sea no O sea sí pero
al mismo tiempo no quiere ir no quiere
ir la situación es un poco complicada No
quiere ir pero la gente que lo sigue que
la sigue le empuja Entonces está
totalmente de acuerdo con eso vamos qué
va a pasar también con el proceso de la
justicia no porque es una institución la
Corte Suprema de Justicia justamente que
una batalla entre el oficialismo y la y
la Corte Suprema que ha anulado dos
selecciones provinciales si me equivoco
porque quieren revocar a dos en
Argentina porque efectivamente anular
dos elecciones provinciales que son la
que tenían que tener lugar el próximo
domingo en San Juan y tucumán es un acto
que cuestiona pone en cuestión la
justicia provincial de las Cortes
provinciales y más allá de eso hay un
cuestionamiento de la Corte Suprema de
Justicia por la composición de la Corte
Suprema que está compuesta por jueces
que son que son que fueron nominados que
en todo caso que responden a una
oposición al oficialismo y por 23
magistrados
algunos de los cuales están siendo ahora
tienen fueron objeto de un de una
demanda de juicio político por el el
gobierno actual eso es es muy actual
digamos fue una demanda juicio político
que fue emitida días después de la
condena de Cristina Entonces es una
batalla vamos a ver cómo qué qué es lo
que lo que esta cuestión va a desenlazar
digamos en los próximos días pero de mí
por mudo de ver hay necesidad de una
reforma profunda de la justicia en la
Argentina eso era poca pimienta todavía
tenemos este enfrentamiento sobre la
antes hablamos de la atracción de los
jóvenes aún por la figura de Cristina
Fernández una figura que es polémica que
tiene sombras que ha sido condenada
aunque ya se victimice que quiere seguir
mirando el futuro cuando ya gobernado
dos veces el país porque esa atracción
porque no no demandan los jóvenes una
renovación aunque sea dentro de del
peronismo porque el kirchnerismo sigue
hacia adelante por qué no dar Un paso
atrás por el bien del país
es uno de esos personajes que tiene que
seguir ligado al poder cueste lo que
cueste hay varias cosas interesantes hay
análisis
una muy simple es que forma parte de la
renovación dentro del peronismo hay que
ver también en el contexto histórico y
más la más amplio O sea hay peronismo
conservador muy reaccionario muy
tradicionalista digamos en Argentina y
fue cuestionado por el cristianismo que
representaba el progresismo en su
momento la segunda cuestión que eso
abarca y digamos concierna todos los
campos todos los partidos políticos es
una cuestión de de profesionalización de
la política el hecho de querer
digamos
ajustarse o agarrarse a los puestos y
luchar solo por los puestos políticos
hizo que vemos acá en Europa en otros
países está dándose también en Argentina
y es por eso Por ejemplo que el
candidato que era que se iba a postular
a la provincia de San Juan
digamos una una vez que la que la Corte
Suprema determinó que las elecciones no
podían darse en San Juan se retiró de la
de la de la candidatura a vicegobernador
diciendo no es Yo no voy por los cargos
Nada más eso es un indicador de una una
necesidad que es una necesidad
importante para el cristianismo también
para todo lo para todo el espectro los
espectros políticos en Argentina de
cuestionar la profesionalización de la
política esta idea de
jugarse solamente por los cargos
entonces pasar a discutir argumentos y
una lucha más bien política ideológica
en Latinoamérica es complicado hay que
ver también es un conjunto y en
Argentina pasa lo mismo Mauricio macri
no quiere ir Alberto Fernández no quiere
ir eso muestra también que ahora también
lo podemos comparar otros países que en
Argentina estamos también en una
democracia también enferma entre comida
de hecho se cumplen 40 años de
democracia en Argentina y la sociedad
Bueno pues está más polarizada que nunca
poniendo el zoom que ha mostrado la
evolución de estos 40 años hasta llegar
a esta campaña qué dirían que ha
mostrado esta evolución de 40 años en
Argentina si pudiéramos definirla en
grandes trazos bueno que sobre todo es
muy dependiente del Progreso económico
mismo del país porque eso es lo que
vimos se abre el país después la
dictadura entre Raúl alfonsín intentan
dominar un poco la inflación la pobreza
comentó mucho durante la dictadura no y
de prácticamente dobló durante la
dictadura y
no funcionó muy bien la inflación llegó
hasta ocho mil nueve mil por ciento con
alfonsín menem sube trata de dominar eso
consigue dominar con su programa peso en
los 90 e iba todo muy bien en ese
sentido bueno liberaliza la economía se
privatizaciones que fueron cuestionadas
por cuestiones de corrupción
evidentemente
pero De cierto modo estabilizó por eso
tuvo mucho apoyo por eso fue reelecto
problema es que después siguió con los
mismos pecados de siempre El pecado de
siempre es el clientelismo que va
a incurrir en una un déficit fiscal
falaminoso en Argentina y ese es un gran
problema en Argentina el déficit que no
para porque hay un clientelismo político
presente cae Argentina quema todas sus
reservas entre de la rúa
la ucr crea la oposición no consigue más
manejar no consigue más mantener ese
sistema que evidentemente vació los
cofres las reservas de dólares del país
cae otra vez el peso tenemos otra vez un
problema de una crisis los kirchner
llegan consiguen estabilizar el país sin
embargo el país está aislado
internacionalmente en términos
financieros macri intentó reintegrar
prometió eso al comienzo todo el mundo
urraurra problemas que no planeo nada no
tenía apoyo tampoco parlamentario eso
también es otro problema en la Argentina
Ah hay que ver que las elecciones
actuales van a renovar la mitad del
Congreso
buenísima síntesis que nos ha hecho
Gabriel en un minuto de 40 años de
Argentina ha sido estupendo
para completar yo creo que hay dos
debates importantes que están pendientes
en Argentina uno se le adeuda externa y
el modelo de desarrollo económico de la
Argentina o sea no solo el modelo
financiero sino el modelo de desarrollo
económico que se quiere si es un modelo
de sociedad industrializada que no no
fue el modelo elegido En todo caso por
macri y lo segundo es la crisis social
que todavía continúa y la deuda para las
mujeres
que es el culebrón Messi como todo en
Argentina es un quilombo también
Muchísimas gracias a los tres ha sido un
placer estaremos muy atentos a lo que
pasa en Argentina en los próximos meses
y a todos ustedes hasta la próxima
semana quien en Primera Plana gracias